HE WE GO DANTE FABBRO BACK IN
THE LINEUP.
HE HAS MISSED  STOP BYIS
BENNETT.GREAT TIP.
IN THE FO
MATTHEW HIGHMORE, OPPORTUNGOING
LEFT OUT OF SAUCE.TWO
CANUCKS.
NICE JOB BY PEARSON TO GET ECON
THE WRONG WAY.
JO
A MISSILE BY BY MYERS.
A LOOK AT THAT DEFLECTION,
RIGHT ON THE INSIDE OF THE
POST.
ABSOLUTELY NO CHANCE
A 360 SPINNER AND SOMEHOW IT
GOT BY JUUSE SAROS.
GAME IS
I DON'T KNOW IF HE GETS TIPS
SLOT.  UR HOPING AS THE SHOOTER
THAT HIT THE BACK
GOT THE SHIVERS THERE BECAUSE
THAT WAS A FLASHBACK TO THE
I
LETTING THAT ONE TIME AGO.
AND LOOK AT THAT SHOT.
PATTERSON BOUNCING AROUND,
TEASES UP.  BACK AND
HERE IS FILIP  TO THE JACK
TWO ON ONE COMING BACK.
MATT DUCHENE ABLE TO WORK
AHEAD.
BACK TO FORSBERG.
>> HE DIDN'T QUITE GET UP AS
MUCH AS HE WANTED TO. PERFECT P
GOAL FOR NASHVILLE TO BACK, EKH
EVERYBODY'S GOING THERE.
TIM RUTHERFORD NOW IS RUNNING
THE SHOW
STRETCHES LEADS TO TWO AT 1:28
HERE IN THE THIRD.
DE OF THE
NET BUT DEMKO COMES FLYING
ACROSS AND WATCH THEM RIGHT
HERE, HE'S SENT TO THE MIDDLE.
REBOUND, TOMASINO STOPPED BY
DEMKO.
REBOUND SENT TO THE NET. JEANNO
FORSBERG KEEPS THE PUCKCK
THAT HIGHLIGHT GOAL IN SEATTLE
TO JUMPSTART THE TEAM.
NASHVILLE NASA HAS A 211.
FIRES AND